Chris oh hi Susan orange of game life I
hear you here for a GBC this week I am
in fact it's very exciting oh cool cool
what are you doing oh you know I'm just
checking out the first reviews for a
game line for the video episode one oh
yeah
oh well here's one man watching him made
me throw up a little in my mouth what a
sickly looking kid get the chick on
maybe that'll be an improvement people
are so stupid you can't be on game life
Susan you can't just go on game Latisse
years of acting lessons vocal training
it I don't even know if I have any
foundation in your shade no idea what's
so complicated I'm sorry oh well you you
should be look who needs the color what
an interview with ninja gaiden - is Tom
oh no we eat a gawky of course I'd loved
only if that nice girl Susan Arendt can
come all right fine but you get your own
makeup
the sooner continua moon simply put the
first ninja gaiden was a game where your
enjoyment of the game was based on
whether or not you could defeat the
enemies there was a threshold there
where if you were able to defeat the
enemies then you had problems a game if
you couldn't defeat them then you didn't
have fun so I just like to make that
clear the outset so a very clear concept
that we have for the sequel Ninja Gaiden
2 is of course to keep the satisfaction
and the fun you get from defeating the
enemies but also make the actual process
of combat whether you win or lose just
as fun so that you're enjoying every
minute that you're actually playing a
game for instance in the first game if
you swung the sword once there was no
fun involved with that there wasn't
there there wasn't any fun being born
until you actually defeated defeated the
enemy but here just simply swinging a
sword once and you know you could have
an enemy dismembered so it's arm shoots
off and blood is spurting out so you get
that visual impact and you're getting
that that ecstasy just from you know
that single attack so the core gameplay
elements are going to allow you to you
know constantly be enjoying what you're
doing throughout the entire game and
that's one of the biggest concepts and
biggest changes this time around so I'll
promise to you right here and right now
that virtually all of the gamers that
you mentioned that you know have loved
ninja gaiden in the past will understand
the new challenges and the new
adventures I'm trying to make with this
sequel and will realize that it's just
as challenging and it's just as
forward-thinking as the previous game
was and they're gonna love it I can
promise you that
I've already you know mentioned this in
a lot of different places but the first
Ninja Gaiden was not a masterpiece
people say it was but it wasn't there
was a lot of noise there was a lot of
compromise there was a lot of things
that went in there that looking back you
know we didn't like so the key is that
for Ninja Gaiden 2 were breaking it down
you know we went back in we basically
destroyed the entire game and only took
what we thought was absolutely
absolutely essential for the Ninja
Gaiden experience and purified that and
now we're building a new game on top of
that so everything that's in there from
the obliteration tech
to the new weapons and all the new game
mechanics are all built on a core
foundation of the elements that we know
are essential to the series so I mean I
think that people will be very happy
with it say yeah if there was any rival
title it would probably be something
like god of war three years obviously
it's a long way away so we don't know
what kind of game it's gonna be but they
have a large fan base and obviously they
have a reputation for for quality games
so I'm interested to see how that plays
out obviously their their philosophy is
completely different from ours
you know Ninja Gaiden 2 is a little bit
more pushing that envelope and trying to
add new elements where you know God of
War has a little bit of budding button
mashing a little bit more a kind of
pre-programmed gameplay I think one
thing that will be interesting to see is
the God of War series was very much
about how to create a compelling action
game within the confines of the
PlayStation 2 hardware but now when
they're working on next generation on
ps3 it'll be interesting to see without
as many limitations if how much they're
able to expand on that I don't make
games for other game developers nor am i
trying to transmit any sort of
information or philosophy to other game
developers I mean you know I do this for
the fans and for the people out there
that want to you know play my games so
when you're talking about an event like
GDC which is really you know an event by
game developers for game developers you
know then I don't really have a whole
lot of interest in you know that event
in and of itself now I won't say that
you know there's no point to it I think
GDC is a very important event and I
certainly respect and you know realize
what they're trying to do here but it's
just that you know a personal choice
some day maybe when I've matured and
become a little bit more well-rounded
like Peter Molyneux I may decide to come
and you know give advice and give
lectures on how to make games right now
I'm really more focused on know my own
and endeavors
you